SARA ROBINSON: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Interpreting ML
Models with Explainable AI.
My name is Sara Robinson.
I'm a Developer Advocate
on Google Cloud.
This is an overview
of what I'm going
to be covering in this session.
I'm going to start by defining
some key terms related
to model explainability.
Then we'll see some examples
of what explainability looks
like for different data types.
Then we'll dive into the
Explainable AI offerings
that we have on
Google Cloud today.
And finally, we'll see them in
action with some live demos.
So let's get started.
We're going to start by
defining "explainability."
Now, in order to
understand explainability,
I want to set the
stage and tell you
how it fits into the larger
concept of Responsible AI.
Responsible AI is
essentially the practice
of ensuring that AI benefits
society and doesn't reinforce
unfair bias.
So you can think of Explainable
AI as an umbrella concept,
and explainability
is a sub-field
within Responsible
AI, in addition to
other topics like fairness,
privacy, and security.
So this is a summary
of how explainability
fits into the larger
Responsible AI picture.
I want to talk about "fairness"
and "explainability,"
since they're two
terms and concepts that
work together and can
sometimes be confused.
So when I talk
about fairness, I'm
talking about ensuring that
machine learning models don't
reinforce biases,
and subsequently,
that they treat all
different slices of users
of a machine learning
model fairly and equitably.
Explainability is one
way to ensure fairness.
"Explainability"
refers specifically
to understanding how and
why a machine learning
model makes predictions.
But explainability
can also be used
outside the context of fairness
to do something like, maybe,
explaining why a fraud
detection model flagged
a particular transaction
as fraudulent.
Explainability is
a broad concept,
and can invoke a variety
of related concepts,
depending on who's
looking at it.
So maybe for an executive that's
overseeing AI investments,
they might think
of explainability
as transparency,
accountability, or governance.
In this presentation, we're
going to focus specifically
on model explainability, which
is understanding how machine
learning models
make predictions,
and communicating the
insights from that
to external
stakeholders and folks
within an organization that
are building these models.
So now let's see some examples
of what model explainability
looks like.
This depends largely
on the type of data
that you're working
with, the data that you
use to train your model.
So explainability is going to
look a bit different for image,
text, and tabular models.
So let's take a look.
For image models,
explainability can
highlight the specific
pixels or regions
in an image that caused
a model to predict
a certain label for an image.
So in this example, the
image on the left of the dog
is the original image,
and the other two images
show different methods
of getting attributions
for the pixels in an image that
signal the model's prediction.
For text models,
explainability can tell us
the words in a block of
text that contributed
to a model's prediction.
So in this example, the sentence
"How could you not love cake?",
which our model gave a
sentiment score of 0.9,
we can also see the words
that contributed most
to that model's prediction
of a high sentiment.
And this is an example of how
explainability and fairness can
go hand-in-hand.
So in a text, specifically
a sentiment analysis model,
you'd want to make sure
that your model wasn't
using identity terms to
determine the model's
sentiment.
In this example, it
looks like our model
is performing correctly
because it's picking up
on emotion words,
than words like "not",
to make its
sentiment prediction.
And then finally,
for tabular models,
explainability gives attribution
values for each of the features
in your model to show how
they influence the prediction.
This particular
example shows a model
that predicts the
duration of a bike trip.
And we can see here that
the distance of a trip
cau-- of this specific
trip caused the model's
predicted trip
duration to decrease,
whereas the max
temperature on that day
caused the model's predicted
duration to increase.
When we talk about
model explanations,
there are a few different
groups of people
that need explanations.
The first group is
data scientists,
people who are
building models, maybe
people who are managing
operations and productionizing
those models.
And for that group
of people, they
want to use explanations
to understand, maybe,
strange behavior in their
model and help debug it,
see why the model's not
performing as they expect,
and try to improve the model.
End users of ML systems could
refer to a few different types
of-- groups of people.
First, it could refer
to someone that's
benefiting from a
prediction of an ML model.
Maybe you're using an
application that gives you
a product recommendation.
It could also refer to a
practitioner, maybe a doctor
or a medical practitioner, who
is using a machine learning
model to determine
whether an X-ray contains
a particular disease.
In this case, they're
using explanations
to verify that they can
trust the model's output.
Finally, we have
public stakeholders,
anyone involved in
regulatory or compliance
for machine learning models.
And this could be somebody
both within or outside
your organization.
They're using
explanations to determine
whether a model complies
with certain regulations,
and if the model is safe
and fit for purpose.
And each of these types of
users will take different action
as a result of explanations.
So just to go over
this a little bit.
So data scientists,
model builders,
people who are actually
building these models,
might use explanations to go
back and see where they could
improve training data, maybe
refine features, or change
the model architecture.
End users are using
explainability
to have more trust in ML
systems and be confident
that the model is leading
them in the right direction.
Finally, public stakeholders
might take action
from explanations by using
higher-level summaries
of models to develop guidance
for different industries
on Responsible AI.
Now let's look at how we can use
Explainable AI on Google Cloud
today.
I'm going to focus
primarily on what's
called Feature
Attributions, but first, I
want to talk about
two categories
of explainable machine learning.
The first is referred to as
"post hoc explanation methods."
This involves looking
at relationships
between feature values and
a model's given prediction,
independent of model internals.
Things like learned weights.
The other type of
explainability is
called "methods that are
interpretable by design."
And this refers
to simpler models,
like linear regression
models or decision trees,
and looking specifically at the
architecture of those models
to understand explainability.
TabNet presents
some new research
in interpretable machine
learning models for tabular
data, and we recently
released a solution for it
on Google Cloud.
Today, I'm going to be
focusing specifically
on post hoc explanation methods.
And within that category,
we'll be looking
at Feature Attributions.
Now let's look at the
products on Google Cloud
where you can use
Explainable AI.
This pyramid
provides an overview
of the different machine
learning offerings
that we have on Google
Cloud, organized
by levels of abstraction.
So the products that are on
the bottom half of the pyramid
are targeted more towards data
scientists and machine learning
engineers, folks that have
more of a background in machine
learning.
As we move towards the
top, these products
are targeted towards data
analysts, application
developers.
Folks that want a way to
integrate machine learning
into their application, but may
not have as much ML experience.
And right now you can
use Explainable AI
on TensorFlow models that
you deploy to AI Platform
Prediction, along with
tabular data models
that you deploy
to AutoML Tables.
And with AutoML Tables, you
get access to Explainable AI
by default. Later on
in the presentation,
I'm going to show live
demos of both of these tools
and how to use
Explainable AI with them.
The first demo is going to
show how to use AutoML Tables.
And in this demo, I'm going
to show a fraud detection
model that was trained on
a public data set that's
available in BigQuery.
And we'll show how we
can use Explainable
AI to get both global and
instance-level explanations.
For the second demo, I built
an image classification model
trained on medical
images using TensorFlow,
and deployed that to AI
Platform with explanations.
For the first model,
I trained this model
using a publicly-available
data set from BigQuery,
and Explainable AI provides
both global- and instance-level
feature attributions
in AutoML Tables.
So this means I can see overall
which features my model relied
on most to make predictions.
And I can also zoom in and
see, at an instance level
for an individual
prediction, which
features were most important
for that one prediction.
For the second demo, I
trained a TensorFlow model
on this chest X-ray data
set available in Kaggle.
And I'm going to show how we're
going to use Explainable AI's
new Local Experience
SDK to get explanations
without deploying our model.
This SDK is available in
Cloud AI Platform notebooks,
and I can use it
to get explanations
on a model that's available
within my notebook's instance
as I'm developing and
prototyping my model,
without needing to
deploy it to AI Platform.
When you're deploying a model to
AI Platform with explanations,
you can choose the
explanation method
that you're going to use.
So I want to introduce
the three explanation
methods that we have available.
All these explanation
methods are
based on
publicly-available research
that you can check out by going
to the links on this slide.
The first method is called
Integrated Gradients.
This works with
all types of models
built with TensorFlow, Tabular,
image, and text models.
Sampled Shapley works for
tabular models built with
TensorFlow, and the X-ray method
is built on top of integrated
gradients, and does
some smoothing to show--
instead of pixel-base
image attributions,
it shows region-based
attributions.
And this is one way that you
could deploy Explainable models
to AI Platform.
Here, we're showing how to do
this using the G Cloud, Google
Cloud, CLI to do it.
So this looks very
similar to how
you would deploy a model
version without explainability
on AI Platform.
The only things you need to
add are the explanation method
you'd like to use and
the number of steps
you'd like this method to use.
And I'll get into that a
little bit more in the demo.
So now let's go to the demo.
I'm going to train
my fraud detection
model using this public
BigQuery data set of credit card
transactions.
Here's a description of
the data and the schema.
Most of the columns in this
data set have been obscured,
and here's a preview of
what the data looks like.
I'm going to run a
quick query to show, as
in the case of many fraud
detection data sets,
the data is heavily imbalanced.
Meaning that only a very small
percentage of our examples
are fraudulent transactions.
So to account for this, I
have done some down-sampling,
which means that I've taken
just a small sample of the data
from our majority class.
And to keep things
interesting, I've
also taken the liberty of
renaming the column names that
were obscured.
So let's look at AutoML Tables.
So to import my data, I
can import it directly
from BigQuery.
So I don't need to
move my data anywhere.
I've already done this,
so let's take a look
at what the data looks like.
I can see a preview of my
columns and the different types
here.
As you can see, I have
renamed many of the columns,
and I selected my target column.
Now, to train my model in
AutoML Tables, all I need to do
is press this
Train Model button.
And to account for that class
imbalance that I mentioned,
in addition to the
down-sampling I did,
I can also use this
Optimization objective
provided by AutoML Tables.
So in this case, I chose to
maximize my model's performance
on the less-common class.
In this case, our
fraudulent transactions.
Now, I've already trained this
model, so let's take a look.
Here, we can see many of
the different evaluation
metrics for our model.
The Confusion Matrix
tells us the percentage
of examples in our test set that
our model classified correctly
for each class.
And here, we care most about
our fraudulent examples.
And we can see that our
model did a pretty good job,
with no false-positives.
And it was able to classify 88%
of our test examples correctly.
Now let's get into
Explainable AI.
So we get this out of the box.
Once we try it in
AutoML Tables model,
we don't have to
enable anything.
What this provides is global
model-level feature importance.
So across our test
set, this shows
us which features
our model used most
in influencing its prediction.
And looks like the
most important feature
here was whether or not there
was a smiley face on the credit
card signature, followed
by the credit card color.
Again, I just made up
these feature names.
And so once we have trained
and evaluated our model,
the next thing we'll want to do
is use it to get predictions.
And there's a couple of ways
to do this in AutoML Tables.
We can do it right in the
UI, which I'll show first.
AutoML Tables has just
populated each feature
with a random value.
And what I want to do here is
check this Generate Feature
Importance box.
Here, we can see the model is
99% confident that this is not
a fraudulent transaction.
And here, we can sort our
feature attribution values
by the ones with the
highest absolute value.
So here, we can see that
smiley face signature caused
the model's prediction
confidence to go down,
whereas the time to expiration
caused the prediction
of confidence to go up.
And we can scroll through
and look at the other feature
attribution values here as well.
So that's how we can
try out AutoML Tables
and see feature importance at
an instance level in the UI.
But chances are, we also
want to use the AutoML Tables
Prediction API to generate
predictions and get
feature importance.
So I'm going to show you how
to do this in a Python notebook
using the AutoML Tables API.
So first, we'll create
an AutoML Tables client,
and we'll set up some
variables for our project,
and a specific model version.
I have provided my
inputs in this format.
This is an example of a
fraudulent transaction,
so hopefully our model will
predict fraud for this one.
And notice here that I am
setting feature importance
to True to get those
feature attribution
values back in my response.
Here, I am visualizing the
feature attribution values.
We can see that our model
predicted this correctly.
97% confidence that this was
a fraudulent transaction.
And here, I've graphed the
feature attribution values just
for the top 5 features.
And we can see which features
influenced our model's
prediction of fraud here.
Now that we've seen an example
of a tabular model using AutoML
Tables, I'm going to show
a few examples of how
to get explanations on an image
model using Explainable AI.
I'm going to show you how to
do it in Cloud AI Platform
Notebooks using
the Explainable AI
SDK, which comes pre-installed
in notebooks instances.
So I'll open up my
notebook instance here,
and in this notebook,
I'm going to show
you two examples of image
classification models
that I built with TensorFlow.
What I'm going to
highlight is how
you can do this all locally
from within your notebook's
instance.
So I'm going to get
explanations on my models
without having to deploy
them to the cloud.
Both of the models that
I'll be using for this demo,
I've already saved in the
TensorFlow SaveModel format
in these directories here.
The first model that
I'm going to show you
is a model that's been trained
on the ImageNet data set, which
can classify images into
1,000 different labels,
ranging from different types
of animals, food, plants, et
cetera.
So I've already saved
the model assets
in the TensorFlow SaveModel
format into this directory.
And note that I'm importing
the Explainable AI SDK here.
What I point the SDK
at this directory,
it's going to generate
some metadata that it will
need to provide explanations.
We can see it save this
in a JSON file here.
And now we're ready to send
a test image to the model.
I'm going to send it this
image of a jellyfish.
I'm going to see both
what label the model
returns for this image,
along with the feature
attributions to explain
that prediction.
And again, to do this, I
am using this Load Model
From Local Path method.
And I didn't need to deploy
my model to the cloud
to take advantage of this.
What we see here is the
label index for the label
that my model is
most confident in.
And below, we can see
that the index of 108
corresponds with the label
of "jellyfish", which
is a good sign, because this
is, indeed, a jellyfish.
And looks like our model was 96%
confident in that prediction.
And just so you understand what
these color-coded explanations
mean, the yellow, brighter
regions in the image
are the regions that contributed
most to my model's prediction.
The darker,
purple-colored regions
are the regions that were
least important in predicting
this label.
And so what we're
trying to see here
is that our model is picking
up on the right shapes that
are associated with
this particular label.
And in this case, we can
verify that our model
is performing correctly.
It's looking at shapes
in this image that
are specific to that
of a jellyfish, which
we can see here.
The next model we'll
look at is a model
that was trained on a
chest X-ray data set
in Kaggle to predict the
presence of one condition that
can be found in these images.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is save our model metadata.
And here, we're
explicitly setting
the baseline for this model
to be a solid black image.
And that's what all
of our explanations
will be relative to.
We can preview
the metadata here.
So we're going to test out
our model using this image.
And our model output
is a sigmoid output,
which means that it's going to
output a value between 0 and 1,
with 1 indicating that the model
thinks a specific condition is
present.
0 indicating that it does not.
So we'll first get
an explanation.
And notice here that we've set
our model's step count to 10.
This is the number
of integral steps
that the explanation
method is going
to use in computing the
pixel attribution values.
And we can see here that the
approximation error exceeds 5%.
Now, what this means
is that we may not
be able to trust
the explanations
in this particular example.
One way that we can
decrease this error
is to increase the number of
integral steps we're using.
So let's try increasing
the step count to 50,
and generate a new explanation.
Now, we can see that
the approximation error
did decrease significantly.
But looking closer at
this image, the regions
that our model seems
to be focusing on
are not the correct
regions associated
with this particular condition.
For this particular
image, our model
should have predicted
closer to 1.
This is likely pointing to
a problem with our model,
or a need to improve
the data that
was used to train our model.
Since explanations are
only a direct reflection
of your model,
they're only going
to be as good as
your model itself.
So it looks like here we
need to go back and improve
our training data.
Perhaps provide a more
varied representation
of X-rays that have
this specific condition
present, and healthy x-rays.
Once we have a model
that we're happy with
and the explanations confirm
that our model is performing
correctly, we have
everything right here
ready to go to deploy
our model to AI Platform.
So all we would
need to do is copy
this directory with
this metadata file
to Google Cloud Storage,
and we could do that here.
And then we would
run this G Cloud
command to deploy our model.
And now let's go
back to the slides.
And finally, here's
some resources
if you want to get started
with any of the products
that I covered in
this presentation.
I definitely recommend
checking out our sample code.
We have some example
notebooks that
show you how to deploy
explainable models on AI
Platform.
Thank you for watching.
If you to get in touch,
you can find me on Twitter
at @Srobtweets.
And I hope you enjoy
the rest of Next on Air.